with all its in-jokes surprise reveals
and many many ghost faces the end of
Scream 6 isn't as clear-cut as you'd
think let's break it down spoilers ahead
to understand the ending of Scream 6
fans must remember the rules of a
franchise of course Mindy is here to
give the characters and fans the lowdown
in a scene that not so subtly pays
tribute to her late great Uncle Randy
push the laws and you end up dead okay
I'll see in the kitchen with a knife
first and foremost Mindy's number one
rule is that everything is bigger than
the last one number two the Woodsboro
group needs to expect the opposite of
what happened last time and most
chillingly number three dictates that no
one is safe and the Legacy characters
are cannon fodder but wait there's more
episodic continuation indicates that the
final characters are also Expendable in
some ways this is a misdirection in
itself because the movie has the best
survival rate of characters we actually
care about of any movie in the screen
franchise with that being said Mindy
does say to expect the unexpected and
the movie certainly lives up to that by
the end
though Neve Campbell announced that she
wouldn't appear in Scream Six fans
didn't quite believe it until the movies
end it wouldn't be the first time the
franchise intentionally misled the
fanbase but Campbell told people back in
August of 2022 I did not feel that what
I was being offered equated to the value
that I bring to this franchise and have
brought to this franchise for 25 years
you know they always say it goes back to
the original here's the original
she also called out the production for a
double standard women face in this
industry adding I honestly don't believe
that if I were a man and had done five
installments of a huge Blockbuster
franchise over 25 years that the number
that I was offered would be the number
that would be offered to a man Campbell
did stick to her guns even though fans
half expected her to show up Gail
mentions early on in the movie that
Sydney deserves her happy ending and on
some level she's right though Campbell's
continued status as the series final
girl set scream apart from other horror
franchises fans would have been gutted
if their favorite final girl ended up in
a body bag Sydney's absence from the
movie is more than palpable and it's sad
that Campbell wasn't valued more however
fans also speculated that Campbell's
decision may have stemmed from the fact
that the franchise wanted to kill Sydney
in this installment and were offering
the actress way too little money to do
it so there's a chance that Campbell
just saved Sydney's life and for that we
can all be grateful
one death that fans surely expected to
happen in Scream 6 is that of Gail
weathers her intro to the movie is
disheartening at best and she seems to
have lost all of the character growth
she developed throughout five films
however we do get some Sydney callbacks
when Sam tries to punch Gail and Tara
succeeds Gail also offers Sam one
wholesome nugget before her Showdown
with Ghostface telling that she can make
her own family despite her past even if
that is with just one person Sam
definitely found that family with Dewey
and Sydney Gail proceeds to have one of
the most epic showdowns with Ghostface
that we've seen yet including a moment
where we think she just might win after
hanging up on Ghostface calling him back
and sussing out his location however he
stabs The Living Daylights out of her
and she tells Sam and Tara to tell
Sydney that Ghostface never got her
shockingly the sentiment Rings true and
we find out at the end of the movie that
Gail survived her injuries
the minute Chad and Tara finally kiss it
seems like his fate is sealed the final
girl's love interests don't tend to last
very long after all unsurprisingly Chad
gets brutally stabbed by two ghostfaces
while he's kissing Tara and despite
being utterly mauled the group still
side eyes Kirby as the killer however
Scream 6 serves screamed two Vibes and
the Ghostface reveal is no different
both films take place out of Woodsboro
as the surviving high schoolers try to
leave their past behind only to find the
effort futile this time though there are
three killers after stumping fans on the
identity of the three ghost faces Chad's
apparently sweet and nerdy roommate
Ethan reveals that he's wearing Nancy
loomis's mask and that's when things
click into place this is a Revenge
driven Family Affair as soon as a very
alive Quinn removes her mask and reveals
that she's the second Ghost Face we
immediately know who's behind Ghostface
number three detective bayley naturally
he's Richie's father hell-bent on
avenging his serial killer son's murder
The Showdown with the killers has all
the quips and twists you'd expect of a
Scream movie Tara aptly congratulates
detective bayley for his Stellar
parenting skills while Sam tells him
that his loser son was a man baby that
made his girlfriend do all of the work
Ethan stabs Kirby with the knife from
her original stabbing to add some poetry
to the moment of course incel
extraordinaire Charlie Walker was guilty
of stabbing Kirby in Scream 4. so it's
unsurprising that the new film's in cell
virgin wields his knife he even later
grossly tells Tara that he did always
want to stick something in her luckily
Tara quite literally gets the drop on
him when she falls from a balcony and
stabs him right through his smart mouth
Quinn meanwhile gets shot in the head by
Sam at this point Sam's killer
Tendencies are in high gear and she
wants to play channeling her father and
OG killer Billy Loomis she calls bayley
using the Ghostface voice but Sam really
claims her Birthright when she Dons her
father's ghost face mask
Sam assures bayley that though her
father was a murderer she's better than
that however on second thoughts
sometimes you don't have a choice for a
moment Sam makes Bailey think she's
saving him but just for a moment because
then she stabs him in the face father
Billy would be proud is that motive
enough for you
Richie's home video is still playing on
the screen as his father dies adding
another layer of nuance to the ending
after bayley takes his last breath these
words flash over a flaming mask on the
theater screen written and directed by
Richie Kirsch his family after all was
trying to finish his movie as were the
two idiots in the film's opening but
like Nancy Loomis and Robbie himself
they learned that no matter how hard
they try they're not the main characters
in this story and avenging the murder of
a serial killer is a futile death wish
it never works out for the dips in The
Mask sticking to tradition there has to
be at least one Ghostface Resurrection
moment in the movie and there is Ethan
barrels back onto the scene only to find
a very alive Kirby she smashes his head
through the TV that killed Stu mocker
way back in the first scream here Kirby
finally gets her revenge on her would-be
murderer Charlie through an in-cell
surrogate and that's more poetic than
any of Bailey's ramblings
there aren't a whole lot of OG
characters to give Sam and Tara advice
at the end of the film since Gail is
busy dealing with a slew of stab wounds
Kirby takes on that role she and Sam
went to high school together after all
she tells the sisters that Legacy
doesn't always have to be a bad thing
Sam proves this time and time again when
she Embraces her mental health struggles
and her cursed family lineage but
chooses not to become another
cold-blooded killer in her family line
she yearns to understand Billy but she
refuses to become him sure she Teeters
on the edge of Good and Evil sometimes
but her moral compass still keeps her
grounded while allowing her to have a
little fun with the people who make her
life a living hell struggling with a
desire to keep a piece of her father
with her as morbid as it is Sam looks at
his crumbling ghost face mask that she
swiped from the theater giving it a
moment's thought she discards the bloody
reminder of her family's past on the
Rainy Street silently vowing to make her
own legacy
though Mindy's initial rules state that
anyone can die in a franchise no one
important really does besides Mindy's
girlfriend Annika Kirby and Gail's
survival is vital because the one thing
that's always worked about this series
comes from the sequels anchoring the
plot with the characters and themes of
the first film most sequels Peter off
after number two or three and people
stop caring because it doesn't in some
way involve the ogs the new characters
can more than stand on their own on that
front but keeping the original Spirit
Alive helps keep the franchise kicking
even without Sydney one of the best
character developments in Scream 6
involves Chad who's become more like our
beloved wholesome Randy and less like a
typical jock and shockingly he turns up
alive at the end of the movie earlier in
the film he coined the moniker core 4
for the film's Woodsboro teen survivors
when Tara asks how the hell he's still
alive he simply holds up four fingers in
this moment she finally gives into his
goofy nickname finally Randy can rest
easy knowing that the wholesome nerd
gets the girl Chad May wear a
Letterman's jacket but at the end of the
day he's a protective sweetheart
alternatively Mindy is the horror expert
with a biting Edge they're the perfect
Meeks twin combo the fact that they all
survive is a breath of fresh air having
the OG movies core 3 Sydney Dewey and
Gail survive for so long in short the
franchise's continued popularity but few
can argue that Randy got killed too
early having the core 4 make it through
for now writes that brutal wrong don't
you know the rules
each Scream movie is undoubtedly a
product of its time and that Rings true
for most of the franchise's handling of
mental health issues the Scream movies
are quite guilty of throwing around
offensive terminology to describe mental
illness while the newer flicks still
follow the theme of outdated language on
that front they've done much better at
giving us some positive representation
of mental health struggles that don't
automatically result in serial killer
Behavior Sam goes to therapy during the
movie and she even tries to convince her
sister to attend a session on more than
one occasion it's lovely to not only see
Sam take her medication regimen
seriously but to work hard at digging
through some of her past trauma so she
can begin to heal sure her therapist
kind of sucks and he dies for it but
this representation of mental health has
been desperately needed in scream for
over two decades finally Tara agrees to
follow her sister's lead on the therapy
front after they defeat Ghostface maybe
there will be some family sessions in
store for scream 7.
let's face it Marvel movies have started
an out of control Trend when it comes to
post-credit scenes No one feels safe
leaving a movie theater until the very
last credit has rolled and sitting
through those credits is a good way to
get audiences to care about the many
behind the scenes experts who make a
movie work also it's fun to see the
artwork listen to the music and take a
gander at the list of songs used in the
film but scream at its core remains a
satirical horror franchise it exists
primarily to make fun of itself and the
horror genre so naturally fans who wait
around until the last credit has rolled
are in for a sassy treat an exasperated
Mindy returns to the screen to quip that
not every movie needs a post-credits
scene while mocking a cliche the movie
Embraces the cliche at the same time
which is just about the most screamed
thing a sequel can do Wes Craven would
be proud I hear you're a horror fan
blah